a radical looks like this okay so let's
start off by simplifying square roots
and then we can maybe look at cube roots
and other types of radicals like that so
what we're gonna do here is we're going
to start off with like the square root
of 24 for example so how do we simplify
the square root of 24 well there's a
couple different ways one way is you can
divide out a perfect square for example
4 times 6 is 24 but the square root of 4
we know is 2 so we can simplify this to
2 square root of 6 now square root of 6
we there's not any perfect squares we
can divide out of 6 like 3 like 9
lecture which is us square root of 9 is
3 or 16 which is 4 25 which is 5 so this
is as far as we can simplify this one
let's look at another example say we
have the square root of 27
okay 27 we know is the square root of 9
times the square root of 3 because 9
times 3 is 27 but the square root of 9
is 3 and we have the 3 here leftover so
this is not a perfect square let's take
for example larger one like say we have
the square root of 128 so how do we
simplify the square root of 128 well we
can divide out perfect squares like we
were doing here like 4 9 16 25 and
that's fine but sometimes when the
numbers get a little bit larger what you
might want to do is do a prime
factorization tree so what I recommend
often times it's just go ahead and break
that number down okay so we can see 64
times 2 8 times 8 let's see 4 times 2 4
times 2 okay you just keep simplifying
and then what you do is you look for a
pair meaning like two of the same number
they don't have to be twos they just
have to be the same number but here's a
pair of twos here's another pair and
here's another pair ok and it looks like
we have one two left over so for each
group you end up with one of those
because this represents 4 square root of
4 is 2 square root of 4 is 2 square root
of 4 is 2 so this is going to be 2 times
2 times 2 which is 8
with this two left over so this is going
to be eight square root of two so that's